[Music]
what is the craziest way
or like the dumbest way to get arrested
like i have
we've covered a lot of like criminal
stories and like just ways people get
arrested what was like the most
outlandish one y'all come across animal
theft
animal death people like stealing pets
from petco and [ __ ] anything that
crackheads do basically in florida
well my my girlfriend's brother in high
school
stole one of their neighbors cars and
then so when they they robbed them at
gunpoint uh they knew exactly who it was
and where they live yeah so they're
right next door girlfriend's brother was
in jail for three years
what an idiot dumbass yeah pretty stupid
i watched this one um dumb criminal
where
he tried to break into like a
convenience store
and then he came in from the roof but
then the doors were locked from the
outside
inside and then they he couldn't get out
and then so he just sat there
like while the cops came those are the
best videos like i've seen a lot of
video security cameras where like the
the the criminal gets stuck inside and
they you just see them like give up
they're like yeah oh [ __ ] i'm trapped
they embrace their face and they're just
they just kind of like sit there and
like yeah we're done they try to break
open the window with a fire extinguisher
or whatever they just can't get out
they're like a lobster in a tank where
he's like i'm [ __ ]
they do try like one more yep it's there
yeah
oh yep still got the rubber bandies
completely [ __ ] yeah oh [ __ ] that's
terrible
my friend's car his race car got stolen
and the guy the
the thief took it to a car show like a
week later
and then but then on the way out of the
car show
on the street he did a burnout and there
was a cop right there
that pulled him over and that's how he
got his car back dumb asses
well here's another interesting criminal
and
uh he got arrested for doing this he
made over 19911 calls selling egg rolls
huh let that sink in for a little bit he
made over a thousand
nine one one calls trying to sell egg
rolls to
the dispatchers to the police officer so
he's trying to prank him
no one knows hello i have an emergency i
have so many a girl attacking me you
want to buy one
[Laughter]
this guy he didn't he called with no
emergency there was no emergency
in his vicinity in his life he just
wanted to make 911 calls
to sell egg rolls to sell egg rolls and
he kept trying us
did he actually have egg rolls though
because maybe that's the real reason you
get a thousand of them dude yeah but
like a cop came one for every call
a cop was like yo what the [ __ ] man
where's the egg rolls at
oh maybe he didn't deliver and it's
false advertisement so he's going to
jail for that
false advertising yeah it's false did he
get any bites like didn't it was anybody
like you know i'm pretty interested in
these egg rolls
yeah it must have worked for him to keep
calm yeah this is uh
who what who win from memphis not you
who did win not you my friend who you
know what though he did something
nobody's ever tried before yeah
he can say that i'm the first one to
ever done this
it's an emergency huh that's something
it's an emergency
i got an emergency for you i feel like
he had egg rolls he's like what should i
do with these egg rolls
and he just said oh this is the only
phone number i know
nine one one no he's like this is a
whole market an untapped market
that nobody's even tried that's a
[ __ ] genius
he is a genius what was the logic behind
a thousand nine one one calls
a thousand maybe you know what he would
have got the sale in the thousand and
one
that's the mentality you have to have
well technically he made a thousand
a hundred and seventy one since july 15.
so july 15 to now uh 1171 calls 9-1-1
and on september 1st
alone he made 241 calls on that day they
need
to release all because you know they're
all recorded right
oh my god i want to hear i need to hear
his pitch yeah
i need to hear how he did this like that
is
smart i just want to know do you want to
buy one job you wanna buy two don't buy
three no
like i didn't even get there 911. do you
have an emergency
[Laughter]
41 42 what about 43 what's about 45.
no 46 no 47
no 40 maybe give him a job at this one
of
those
chinese scam caller places dude he would
be amazing at that that's true
that's true but yeah so um it has not
been revealed whether
uh who win was actually selling egg
rolls or simply trolling the emergency
service which is
really the reason why he got arrested
they're just like you're calling way too
much it wasn't even about the egg rolls
they're clogging up the phone lines
is [ __ ] weird what if he's a true
businessman
persistency is key here maybe we're
looking at this all wrong right
like okay how should we look at it so
you know you remember when you're a kid
and you just find out about prank calls
oh i've done that before right i've
called that one before
here probably just learned about prank
colin
and he's like this is so funny you guys
check this out
one stick that's it yeah so then when
his friends come over they drink and
he's like look at this [ __ ]
9-1-1 and then his friends are sitting
there bored he's like no one more time
and they're like
you've done it a thousand times it's
been one thousand times
he puts it on speakerphone hey you want
an egg roll
okay bye you're the only one laughing
man yeah
he's like watch this they sound so
worried sir what's your emergency
see they still care about me
they don't know me and they love me
watch this [ __ ]
the prank calls are hard to do though
because like i remember yeah you guys
tried doing it for like constantly
what do we call home depot in alhambra
yeah we started
laughing like crazy what was the setup
well
the thing is i was in a character so i
had a wig on
and all that stuff and we made the call
and i almost [ __ ] broke character
because we tried to do it one take right
and we were making up [ __ ] on the spot
and i was like
saying that my i want to return the
lumber that got termites in
oh yeah i just wanted to return the
lumber
and it would let me and he said it's my
fault because i left it outside
[Music]
and then i started to think sad and you
were really nice about it
oh god we're service workers dude i went
to mcdonald's this past week to get that
travis scott burger i just wanted to try
it
how was it good it was actually not bad
it was okay i wouldn't get it it's just
a quarter pounder with lettuce right
yeah yeah so we were at the drive
through and then my friend goes
you guys got that travis scott burger
and the guy goes
sure do and i was like oh jesus christ
my friend goes you okay bud he goes i
work at mcdonald's
he's supposed to say that that was
really bad would that be tight if every
mcdonald's worker had to go
oh my god awful would that be anything
else no okay
just to humiliate their own workforce
it's a good job guys no it's a great job
oh yeah you know when you work in
customer service it's always that one
like it's always those people who think
they're the first person that came up
with a [ __ ] joke
and i hated it so when did it happen to
you when i was a hostess
and um uh so like you know we can't seat
everyone like all the tables some tables
are empty because we don't have servers
there
and then or like or like if you just
work at a restaurant they're like oh and
then the charge didn't go through
because it's free isn't it shut the [ __ ]
up or how about
how about your plates empty and they're
like oh how was it like oh we hated it
terrible
we've done that joke baby go back and
shoot myself right now
all right there was this one guy like i
don't know why it pissed me off so much
um i sat them and like have a great meal
he goes don't tell me what to do
i'm just like okay he goes just kidding
i'm like you [ __ ]
he's trying to have a good time but the
thing is his face was so
serious i'm like [ __ ] god like and i
didn't know what to do about him like
okay or don't [ __ ]
cop do whatever the [ __ ] you want there
is an underrated amount of there's an
underrated amount of debt comedy
happening at these restaurants yeah
that people don't even register
understand or appreciate that's true
because it's lame it'll be up to you
oh when i used to be one of those like
naked sushi models with like they cover
you in sushi
and there's always a dude there's always
a dude
can i eat you oh my god i'm going to pee
on this table right now
are you allowed to talk when you're
doing that yeah you engage in the
conversation
so i mean you're you're like this right
and what do you do like do you turn over
and be like
what like it's like surgery like
she like drops off your body yeah it's
kind of like there
and you feel like the sushi you're just
like huh
i mean for the most part people are cool
like you sit there and tell you how's it
going you know just later how's it going
like it's the easiest job ever but just
there's always those [ __ ] people are
like so they put banana leaves on you
first
put banana leaves on you and then
flowers and then they lay the sushi
there's no like skin
skin to food so the oh so the banana
leaf is like your banana bikini yes
yeah yeah and it's always gonna eat you
or there's always
can i take the leaf say i won't [ __ ]
myself right now i'm doing this whole
thing for everyone
[ __ ] hate it in here but what if it
was a really really hot guy
and you're like you take whatever the
[ __ ] you want it's just usually
it's not right yes you got a team of
walruses around you yeah yeah
what is the what is the average customer
that does
the eating sushi off a person what is
that person i'm imagining old
japanese businessmen no i mean it was
like cool it's like like swanky
hollywood parties
yeah it depends on like which party you
have that's like there was a middle
eastern huge birthday party
birthday party oh i don't like that
kid's birthday party
hey timmy you want a piece of sashimi is
it can i eat you
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] on you kid so you're
laying there for like three hours
just an hour oh an hour yeah are you
allowed to fall asleep
no oh do we have an hour like security
we have like security around us and
everything
that's cool that's pretty cool oh if you
do have to go to the bathroom you're
you're kind of [ __ ] up you go before
yeah you kind of [ __ ] but it's okay i
never drink water anyways
i'll be fine are you like you have to
shower and all that stuff or is it like
a hygiene thing you're supposed to do as
the sushi model you show up clean
don't be shitty like don't have lotions
on you or anything but like i said the
food doesn't touch the body at all
right right or like you know what if you
have to sneeze
oh how does it work are you on like a
platter and then they put the leaves on
and then like sushi chefs are just like
putting um sushis on you
and then they roll you out no so um what
it is
is um so we have security we have robes
and then you go and it's like a very
large table like a cushion and pillow
everything on it and then like a very
soft velvet sheet
or like a like a very soft sheet over it
and then
you get on the table we have pasties on
oh and we have
g-strings on too oh and then we lay down
on a table
um but we're covered while we're laying
down and once we lay down
um you know they put the leaf on us
really quickly so no one sees anything
and then that's when they remove the the
you know the cover so they can't see
anything at all
and then they cut the strings on the the
g string so you don't see it
and then the sushi chef starts laying
food on you
and and are the patrons there already or
they enter when the sushi is already on
oh they're there watching him place but
then
they don't see anything prior to the
leaves because we're
there's like a sheep being held up to
cover us first awkwardly watching you
get
sushi made on your body yeah i've only
been to one i was at one party that had
that but
it was already undergoing underway or
whatever so the girls were already just
laid out is it like a buffet where they
come up and then they take
yeah and then or do they sit around the
table they walk up it's like a buffet
oh and i just was i was like she's like
oh hey you're gonna get some sushi i was
like i don't even like sushi
there's like a creepy older couple and
like this guy was like oh my my wife
would love you
ew okay calm down my wife
is it more creepy to be approached by a
couple than it is
by a single guy um no not really because
at least the chick's there it's fine
like i don't really get creeped out
because we have security there you know
or like there's some [ __ ] there's
like this five or six vietnamese older
guy that was like
can i blow off that flower off your
breast when i just looked at him like
no please don't do that i mean it's all
taped down anyways which is like [ __ ]
you try to blow it off
it's not working
you